I'm not against somebody having a
history degree I'm not I'm not against
somebody having a history degree we need
to know history history is important I
like history I would not say I'm a
history buff but there are sections of
history I get really interested in and
dive down into and I think it's very
valuable to know history but if you're a
father out there and you have an 18 year
old daughter right now and she's about
to go sixty thousand dollars to get into
debt to get a history degree you need to
replay that last call you need to listen
to what just what just unfolded
a lady came out of college with a
history degree and $60,000 in student
loan debt
she and her soon-to-be ex-husband ran up
$50,000 in credit card debt borrowed
$10,000 on the car and daddy tried to
help her and loaned her another 20,000
she's got a hundred thirty six thousand
dollars in debt a twenty thousand dollar
income did you hear that call America
and you and I as the taxpayers
guaranteed the loan that led her down
this primrose path and we call that a
student loan and we call that a help to
our culture I missed where the lady got
helped oh by the way it's not bankrupt
able it never goes away it's a single
mom trying to feed three kids and half
of her debt is for a history degree and
her answer to have make more money and
get a career is go back to school again
somebody please smack me unbelievable do
you do you hear the messaging in this
there's something broken and I'll tell
you what it is it's called the student
loan program and it's called you parents
here's an idea parents parent look at
your 18 year old child and don't look at
them like they have any sense they walk
around in adult bodies they don't have
any sense they don't have any sense
they're going to go 60 and 80 and 120
and 4540
thousand dollars in debt to get a
history degree I'm not against history
degrees but for goodness sakes if you're
going to do that pay for it in cash so
you don't have this hanging around your
neck the rest of your life so what's she
going to do she's going to have to
retool on enter a different field in
order to get her income up have the
backbone dad's mom's to look at your
child and say no that course that you're
on that that career path that you are
tracking and the amount of debt you're
going into I'm not going to participate
in that I'm going to look at you and say
you are stupid no no no no love your
child enough when they're 17 and 18
years old to assist them in choosing a
reasonable career path with no debt no
you can't go out of state we don't you
don't borrow money to cross the state
line that's known as stupid stupid you
go to the University of Tennessee if you
live in Tennessee if you live in Alabama
you go to Auburn or you go to Alabama if
you graduate from one of those three
schools you got a good degree in
whatever field you're in to cross the
state line and quadruple the cost of
doing it and not have the money to pay
cash for it
is stupid stupid what you pay like I
went deeply in debt to do what to so I
could go out of state what what you went
into debt to go out of state you didn't
go into debt for your education you went
into debt so you could live in a
one-bedroom apartment with a jacuzzi and
a skylight and a racquetball court and
you called this your college experience
somebody ought to smack you in the next
week
should have been your parents who loved
you enough to stop you from doing it and
not participate in this
I just stuff drives me bananas because I
now I got this little sweet little lady
bless her heart she's just broken she's
trying to raise three kids on her own
and she got $20,000 a year you
understand that's below the poverty
level and she's got a history degree
with $60,000 in credit card debt or in
student loan debt and 50,000 dollars in
credit card debt to go with it and I can
go off for two hours on that one too but
parents parents parents please parent
because your government is stupid
it is We the People the taxpayers were
so stupid we're so enamoured with the
acquisition of degrees that we have
agreed to guarantee loans for 18 year
olds who have no job history
and no assets any banker that made this
loan would be fired for incompetence but
you and I the taxpayers are guaranteeing
this all in the name of the acquisition
of sheepskins as if you don't get a
degree you can't win no honey if you're
stupid you can't win get a degree I'm
all about education but do it in such a
way that you pay for it and that you pay
only for the education you do not
finance the experience on student loan
debts that last for ever they last when
your child is sick
they last when you go through a divorce
they last when your husband dies earlier
your wife dies early they last when your
father gets cancer and you want to go
home and spend time with him they last
forever as your life happens do not sign
up for this stuff it's going on and on
and on and on we all have a trillion
dollars of this stuff oh and by the way
the government agency that's supposed to
love on you and take care of you while
you were so noble that you pursued your
education and We the People guaranteed
your education loans
well this from Huffington Post federal
consumer regulators take an aim at the
Department of Education is preferred
companies for servicing the agencies one
trillion dollars in student loan debts
highlighting potentially poor customer
service really you just found that out
huh and raising the specter of increased
government scrutiny the move relied on
the Education Department surveys which
grade the for preferred companies that
service these loans and determine how
many new loans each will receive in the
coming year to service as a new crop of
students enter college and graduate
Sallie Mae ranks the worst in borrower
school and federal personnel
satisfaction the CFPB official noted
citing the surveys referring to the
Education Department documents that
Sallie Mae will receive the fewest new
loans to service in the upcoming school
year
borrowers stuck with Sallie Mae or any
other servicer who wished to switch to
another have little ability to do so the
apparent public shaming comes as Sallie
Mae contends with numerous probes
including investigations of my federal
banking regulators and the Department of
Justice over its handling of student
loans and treatment of the borrowers
despite Sallie Mae's track record which
Elizabeth Warren describes as a pattern
of breaking the rules and ignoring its
contractual obligations the Education
Treasury Department's appear to have
given little more than a slap on the
wrist of the company so we found out by
doing a survey the federal government
discovered the Sallie Mae's incompetent
where the flip of you people been we've
known that for decades but she's
servicing all these loans that never go
away student loan lasts for ever no
matter what bad things happen in your
life until you make enough money to pay
it off it's not bankrupt able it
survives disability it survives divorce
won't survive disability but it will
take you four years to get it off so
just go ahead and get ready to deal with
Sallie Mae on their incompetent people
on that so we're encouraging people to
do stupid things to get an education we
the people I had a student loan I did it
to almost everybody listening how to
student loan
and so what am i saying I'm saying this
is a bad philosophy and the only way to
preempt it is to educate the moms and
dads and encourage them to be good
parents and educate the 18 s and 17 16
year olds and encourage them to only pay
for education not for crossing state
lines unless you've got the cash to pay
for it and don't go somewhere in school
and run up $200,000 in debt to get a
history degree you'll be what's known as
screwed this is the Dave Ramsey show